stop si je fais une vidéo sur ce jeu
c'est parce que je n'ai pas internet
donc je peux pas téléchargé de jeu est
le seul jeu que j'ai sur mon ordi et que
je n'ai pas fait en vidéo ces temps là
ces malades
du coup bah c'est parti est ce qu'on est
en train de choisir la qualité des
graphismes est ce que c'est une blague
je préfère jouer avec des superbes
graphismes un jeu de simulation de
toilettes quand même que voilà on
ressent vraiment la sensation
donc ouais tu donc ça c'est toi l'aide
pour fans pour homme et pour handicapés
3en à super tjrs un espèce de bruits
d'eau c'est soit le tuyau soit nous qui
d'accord donc cet homme peut faire du
breakdance avec qui se mettent sur la
tête qui tombe sur lui le fait sur les
toilettes où on est petit on est quotas
alors quoi d'autre dans ce super
toilettes
bon déjà c'est un peu glauque car on a
juste une vieille lampe au plafond kit
indique tu n'es pas dans le noir grâce à
moi d'ailleurs il me semble que dans
toutes les toilettes c'est comme ça oui
alors j'ai jamais vu des toilettes
publiques avec un sol aussi parfait que
ça brille c'est luisant c'est pas
possible
alors soit c'est très propre soit c'est
donc là cet homme ne sera jamais en rade
de paix qu un nom plus bas possible bon
à part ça est-ce qu'on peut jouer on
peut juste tourner sur faire du
breakdance sur note sur une cuvette où
zac est aujourd'hui les dance kaka dans
le flore c'est parti
qu'est ce qu'on est en train de faire là
j'aimerais savoir pourquoi pourquoi je
n'avais que se joue je regrette déjà est
maintenant donnons un nom à chacun de
ses faits à le je me retiens de péter
depuis minutes me retiens de faire
quelques minutes personne n'a jamais
fait ça aux toilettes personne c'est pas
possible
moi j'ai plus un truc style voilà une
danse en quelque sorte à aa
et maintenant les élections
présidentielles 2014 votée un pour le t2
pour et voté trois pour ça mais mal à
l'aise de faire des vidéos sur un jeu
comme ça oui je suis plutôt d'accord
mail avantages de cet homme et qu'il
peut tirer la chasse d'eau avec ses
dents voilà comme ça
voilà encore faut-il qu'elle marche la
chasse d'eau et il peut aussi regarder
entre ses jambes son pénis exil
existants pardon voilà c'est comme ça
il n'a ni jambes ni pénis peut-être
qu'en fait c'est une tête volante sur
rase au non dit pas que non et ce
qu'elle fait là est ce qu'il ya une fin
à ce jeu et est ce que ce [ __ ] bruno
qui me donne envie de pisser depuis 20
minutes que s'arrêtent les attentions
c'était un 360 p
mais qu'est-ce qui est sorti les faits
cela mais c'est pes 2014
mais là c'est trop long trop quelle est
la différence entre un paix sans
lunettes et 1p avec lunettes
[Musique]
j'ai l'air plus grave quand j'ai des
lunettes c'est ça que je voulais dire si
un ami à vous sortir de terre publient
depuis environ une heure vous pouvez
simplement le mettre là comme ça devant
votre ordinateur sur ce jeu et avec ces
[ __ ] de bruit de goutelas qui sont là
depuis je ne sais pas combien de temps
votre ami finira pas ce que c'est voilà
c'était le conseil d'enfants du jour
super ai-je le droit de l'étude une
touche pour t'appuyer dessus non alors à
quoi tu sers pour poster tu n'es pas un
vrai bouton de chasse d'or tu n'es cap
vous n'êtes pas du vrai pq pas du vrai
sol où suis-je
et maintenant voici la blague plus
impressionnante du monde c'est sûr d'un
mec qui avait envie d'aller aux
toilettes je faisais quand j'étais petit
j'ai pris des cours de solfège
[Musique]
là cela est nul comme mag
voici la tête des gens qui s'éclatent
sur ce jeu il ya autant de chlore sur ce
short quai dans une piscine municipale
voilà les mots ne sont pas les couilles
s'écoule à elle m'a défoncé sur quoi en
fait j'ai pas si je voulais dit mais ma
ps3 trouver un nouveau partenaire de jeu
vidéo ah ouais c'est rockstar gta déjà
ses faux seins et ensuite c'est une
vraie blague nul mon [ __ ] mais si je
me fais péter un câble quoi moi voilà
écoutez je pense qu'on a fait à peu près
tous les jeux de mots possibles sur ce
jeu un jeu de mots totalement nul il
faut bien le dire
en tout cas je suis désolé de vous avoir
proposé une vidéo sur ce jeu j'avais
vraiment envie de faire une vidéo
aujourd'hui j'avais que ce jeu j'ai fait
ce que j'ai pu
j'espère quand même que ça vous a plu
mais on est d'accord à ont fait plus
jamais ça je suis désolé mais j'ai plus
internet pour une durée inconnue est le
seul jeu que j'ai sur mon ordi et que
j'ai pas fait en vidéo c'était ça voilà
j'espère quand même que vous aurez lâché
un petit lit un petit sourire ah ouais
ou pas du tout restez comme vous êtes
vous êtes top et à bientôt pisse froid
soleil
trop de traces à l'oeil nu
c'est cette salle
[Musique]